all hail the megastretch excuse me
pardon me
oh hey nice party got a present for you
sorry hey guy I got another present for
you
Wow well we'll see about that Wow
you dick now kill the bastard Wow
okay you're gonna die whether you like
it or not and you're gonna dive right
now sucker
hello what's going on in here this is a
lovely house that you have boy this is
nice decoration here oh is that oh
that's what I thought that was whoa why
oh oh this ain't good
Howie sorry I'll fix that I'll pay for
that sorry I'll just try to get in
excuse me pardon oh how are you doing
today
you're doing good lovely home sorry to
interrupt I just decided to go upstairs
for a moment trophy okay ignore that try
I'm gonna come back for another go we oh
god I won but I think it costs you no
longer take off I'm tethered by my head
this seems to be slightly problematic
and also very strange hi buddy okay
let's see what happens
oh this is much better
does anyone else slightly bothered by
any of this just me okay why not yeah
that's normal
wish I didn't know that I was playing
target mode hahahahaha
Oh God
away we go here we are your Howie oh god
why have it over okay Howie
okay back down ow
any minute now
goddammit there we go please help me
even Bonnie can't help me now oh god
damn it
Oh God thank you
oh just kill me now and the pain oh the
pain is not ended in fact it's gotten
worse
damn it I've decided to enter your fine
establishment I'd like to purchase some
takis do you have them here okay never
mind I'll just be on my way then
excuse me good good day sir
the weather's nice but that's okay I'll
just be on my way whenever I can oh okay
holy crap I'd love to join the
festivities how okay
my butt is stuck yeah I guess that's
good look at me
hi Bonnie
I am the most beautiful feather goat
that you've ever seen yeah hello my
loyal subjects I've descended from the
heavens to give you a message you're all
going to die
well y'all killed yourselves well done
Bok Bok Bok Bok Bok Bok Bok Bok Bok my
crack how do you like your new hood
ornament this is delightful gas so
elegant and beautiful can anyone doubt
my own magnificence wow I've got a
rainbow shooting out of my body I'm so
beautiful look at me now hey buddy
how can I be the life of the party now
please please please
come on I'm farting rainbows forever
pervert / I'm faster than you
I'm faster than you Wow excuse me okay
this is pretty much normal for me now
and I'm still going all right I'm very
allergic yeah I know
thanks Barney good food can have some
thank you
well there's no need to be pissy about
it that's here in that table are getting
it on Bonnie why'd you fall over over
there
I'm deal with you later my horse
explained what the hell's going on here
well you're not bothered by me you
actually accept me for who I am okay
here we go oh god stop I'll get off the
ride do not ask me of what I have become
just rank the add-ons big enough yeah
God okay I broke everything I went
further than I've ever gone I am
physically destroyed it all everything
everything is dead